el señor solorio y el tío roberto
quieren saber quién tiene mayores
oportunidades de lanzar un balón de
fútbol americano sobre unas montañas
caray el señor sol oro y el tío roberto
deben de tener buenos brazos para poder
lanzar balones sobre montañas la tabla
mostrada a continuación muestra las
distancias de ocho tiros del señor
solorio la media y la desviación media
están dadas para las distancias de ocho
tiros del tío roberto completa la tabla
y usa las listas desplegables para
comparar al señor solorio y al tío
roberto todos los números están en
metros redondeados al metro más cercano
así que nos dan las distancias medias de
los tiros del tío roberto y luego la
desviación media y si encuentras este
como un término inusual o no estás
familiarizado con él vamos a calcular la
desviación media para el señor solorio y
después espero todo tenga sentido
primero calculemos la distancia media de
todos los tiros del señor solorio y si
vamos al ejercicio original así que
vayamos al ejercicio original
puedes ver que ellos nos dan una
calculadora así que está bien utilizar
una calculadora pero yo lo voy a hacer
en mi blog de apuntes para que sea un
poco más sencillo entonces saquemos la
calculadora y todo lo que tenemos que
hacer es sumar todos estos 8 puntos y
dividirlos entre 8
así que 27
28 más 28
30 más 31
34 más 37
+ 40 así que esta es la suma de mis 8
puntos son 8 tiros en metros y voy a
dividir eso entre 8
para obtener un promedio de 31.875
entonces podemos escribir eso
y ellos quieren que lo redondeamos al
metro más cercano así que la distancia
promedio podemos decir que es 32 justo
así y ahora quieren que obtengamos la
desviación media como nos dijeron que
redondeamos podemos solo seguir usando
esta distancia media eso hará a los
cálculos un poco más sencillos si vamos
al ejercicio original eso es lo que
quieren que hagamos así que sabemos que
esta de aquí es 32 en promedio los tiros
del señor solorio son
más largos que los tiros del tío roberto
por 2 metros en promedio vamos a ver qué
dicen estas listas desplegables
cerca de la mitad de la desviación media
cerca de dos veces la desviación media
cerca de tres veces la desviación media
y estoy asumiendo que están hablando de
la desviación media del señor solorio
así que calculamos la desviación media
del señor solorio y veamos cómo se
relaciona el 2 con ese número de ahí
déjame ir a mi blog de apuntes otra vez
así que desviación desviación desviación
media
la desviación media entre cada uno de
estos puntos es bueno qué tan lejos
están los puntos de esta media y vamos a
usar valores absolutos porque algunas
veces es menos y otras veces es más
grande que la media pero solo queremos
saber qué tan lejos está es una
distancia por lo que siempre queremos un
valor positivo por ejemplo la desviación
media y haremos una pequeña columna aquí
la déjame solo escribir la desviación
absoluta la desviación absoluta de 27 a
22 podemos decir que es el valor
absoluto
- 32
qué es lo mismo que el valor absoluto de
32 menos 27 lo que es igual a bueno esto
es menos 5 pero su valor absoluto es 5
positivo aquí
el valor absoluto de 28
- 32
es igual a 4
el valor absoluto de 28
- 32
y acabamos de calcular eso es igual a 4
el valor absoluto de 30
- 32
eso es menos 2 el valor absoluto es 2
mira 30 estados metros lejos de 32 28
está cuatro metros lejos de 32 27 estas
5 metros lejos de 32 ahora
- 32
es menos uno en valor absoluto es igual
a uno observa que 31 está un metro lejos
de 32 puedes incluso hacer eso en tu
cabeza puedes decir qué tan lejos está
esto de 30 y 25 metros que tan lejos
está esto de 30 y 24 metros y podemos
continuar de esta manera pero sólo
quería mostrarte que estas son las
desviaciones absolutas por lo que
34 - 32
es igual a 2 y luego tenemos 37 menos 32
es igual a 5
y luego el valor absoluto de 40
- 32
es igual a 8
entonces ahora solo tenemos que
encontrar la media de estos 8 números la
media de estas desviaciones absolutas
así que traigamos nuevamente la
calculadora y entonces va a ser
4 + 4
+ 1 + 2 + 5 + 8 e intentemos solo pensar
en lo que es esto cada uno de estos
puntos es qué tan lejos está cada tiro
de la media y ahora estamos diciendo en
promedio qué tan lejos están estos tiros
de la media por lo que estamos
intentando ver en promedio más o menos
cuánto varían estos tiros de la media
así que esta es una manera en la que
medimos eso estas son mis desviaciones
promedios sumadas y voy a dividir las
entre 8 para obtener la desviación media
entonces es 3.875 y quieren que
redondeamos así que podemos decir que
esto es 4
por lo que volvamos al ejercicio
original en el ejercicio original este
de aquí es 4
por lo que en promedio los tiros del
señor solorio son más largos que los
tiros del tío roberto por veamos si son
más largos por 2 metros que es alrededor
de la mitad de la desviación media del
señor solorio entonces elijamos la mitad
de la desviación media del señor solorio
la tuvimos bien